daniel es gab sich als reicher
investmentbanker auf als seine freunde
in drei jahren die lügen aufdeckte
musste sie das mit dem tod bezahlen
heute fiel das urteil im prozess in bad
kissingen lebenslänglich für daniel s
das landgericht schweinfurt verurteilte
den 29-jährigen für den gemeinen messer
mord an der yen h noch zum
prozessauftakt hatte ullrich der vater
der getöteten dreifach mutter eine harte
strafe gefordert
[Musik]
für einen pflegerin dmh war daniel es
ein großer fang einreicher investment
banker mit schicke eigentumswohnung in
bester lage eine lüge denn in wahrheit
war der gebürtige frankfurter nur eine
mehrfach vorbestrafte servicekraft als
der yen von den lügen erfuhr machte sie
schluss doch der damals 28 jährige ließ
nicht locker und umwarb sie mit erneuten
geld versprechungen
schließlich ging der yen h eine schein
beziehung zu ihm ein
als da es davon erfuhr plante er den
mord im märz 2009 10 lockte er die nh
mit dem versprechen eines großzügigen
einkaufs und eines verlobungsringes nach
bad kissingen das paar hatte sex im
anschluss tötete dani es die
altenpflegerin mit 22 messerstichen im
hausflur eines wohnhauses
eine tat im affekt weil die getötete ihm
kurz zuvor von der abtreibung des
gemeinsamen kindes berichtet habe
versuchte daniels zu behaupten eine
zweifelhafte aussage denn wer hat bei
einer ungeplanten tat ein messer dabei
auch das gericht entschied nun kein
totschlag im affekt die tat war geplant
daniel es wurde zu einer lebenslangen
freiheitsstrafe wegen mordes verurteilt
mein kollege jörg völkerling ist vor ort
er hat auch mit dem vater des opfers
gesprochen wird wie fast die familie das
urteil auf
die familie fast das urteil mit
erleichterung auf sie findet sich auch
in der begründung der vorsitzenden
richter eigentlich gut wieder
angelika drescher hat sehr gut fast eine
stunde lang zusammengefasst was für
einen manipulativen charakter
daniel ist eigentlich hatte er hat da
yen habe vorgegaukelt er sein vermögen
der google-manager dass er mit bitcoins
handelt das investment banker sei er hat
sie nach disneyland mit ihren kindern
eingeladen und ihr ewige liebe
versprochen tatsächlich hat er nachdem
sie in ihren seinen sachen gewöhnt hat
und aus fand dass er mehrfach
vorbestraft ist dass er sogar seine alte
eigenen eltern schon geklaut hatte hat
er sie dann wieder gelockt mit geld mit
einem schönen einkauf nach bad kissingen
aber in der nacht vorher hatte er auf
seinem handy ein masterplan verfasst wie
er der letzte in ihrem leben sein sollte
er mit ihr sex hat das letzte lächeln
das sollte ihn gelten mission ewige
liebe hat er das ganze überschrieben
und letztlich hat er minutiös umgesetzt
was er darin beschrieben hatte er hatte
nachdem sie dann weglaufen wollte sie in
den hausflur gezerrt sieben mal auf sie
eingestochen mehrfach sie mit dem messer
verletzt dann mit seinen fäusten auf
ihren hals gedrückt polizeibeamte mit
gezogener waffe standen zehn minuten um
ihn herum und er hat sich nicht
abbringen lassen von dieser tat
neben mir ist jetzt ulrich h ich möchte
ihnen einfach fragen sie haben diesen
prozess jetzt verfolgt sie hatten
befürchtungen dass es mildere strafe
geben könnte wie wie sehen sie jetzt auf
den prozess zu rücken auf das urteil
also ich bin sehr erleichtert über die
höhe des urteils
wie schon gesagt ja ich hatte nach dem
am mittwoch dass der durch die brille
des gehalten wurden
befürchtungen dass es vielleicht beim
strafmaß von 9 bis 15 jahren wie es von
der verteidigung gefordert wurde
enden wird ich war allerdings sehr
überrascht dass die richterin
da
forderung der staatsanwaltschaft und
meines anwalts von der nebenklage
gefolgt ist und es bei lebenslang
geändert ist angeklagter hat ja von der
effektiven tat gesprochen
wie haben sie ihn während des verfahrens
erlebt
ich möchte das so ausdrücken hier ich
hab die den angeklagten ja während der
letzten acht behandlungstage und auch
heute bei der urteilsverkündung ständig
beobachtet
also gleichgültiger kann man dieser
sache nicht erfolgen
selbst heute das urteil hat er
vollkommen emotionslos über sich ergehen
lassen und das zeigt eigentlich für mich
wie kaltblütig und wie berechnet dieser
mensch war
wie behalten sie ihre tochter in
erinnerung
ja
es waren die letzten moment als sie uns
vor jahren
ich hatte mit den kindern
behalte oder unsere ganze familie behält
sie
als eine lebenslustige und
fröhliche frau in einem und so werden
wir das auch
bei beiden
ergänzen möchte ich noch ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich
bei den ermittlern kriminalpolizei in
schweinfurt bedanken die durch eine
wirkliche akribische ort
die ermittlungen geführt haben sonst
wäre das
zu diesem urteil gekommen und das ist
für mich die größte genugtuung
seehofer ja ich habe auch noch kurz mit
einem medley von der kripo gesprochen
auch den fällt hier ein stein vom herzen
sie sagen jetzt ist er zumindest erst
mal die nächsten 15 jahre weggesperrt
jörg völkerling vielen herzlichen dank
aber vor allem auch unser beileid und
unser mitgefühl einen vater des opfers
an dieser stelle